I did Scott alone achoo
oh no I'm not really dead Master Dan has
been foiled
you're just secret
[Music]
and I'm gonna steal a body because you
ran off with my wife and it's all his
fault and definitely not her choice
so yeah she must've gotten crazier so
I'm gonna leave me so uh but things
don't go right and then I do die but
I've had lots of times like sometimes
lost time is great so then in the end I
took over the mayor's body but that's
not quite it our players
I have spirit in my body I've broken
bloody body he wants to go back anyone
forgot stuff it'll crush the story make
sense yeah cool okay you ready yeah this
is going to be gold man that closed my
face all right yeah okay
[ __ ] well [ __ ] we can we go up from that
or is that impossible
[ __ ] let's do it again yeah you got it
your hero all right having that finger
pretty kid behind you partner maybe
maybe a little bit of a motive from
camera movement you know I would because
uh this is a person so if he says
something shocking you know kind of like
real fact like I don't that you have
just barely a little bit to something to
give it all the nuance direction I'm a
man of many talents did you drool did oh
my gosh Hey Baby where you do a
bartender thing you're bored nothing
bored nothing
sending writing yeah Borden Oh Slate's
Oh Justin
good done shot
okay back to Catherine city yeah can t
signal catch Catherine she's in charge
of him here's all you guys doing the
voices in lines and acting stuff you
guys were really solid than that last
one so I think it was all ages and again
people blame the Gimple like for a lot
where it was microbus
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this really a spotlight though tipping
up my crotch is just the highlight on my
resume I was like here we go we're gonna
get this is an observational sport Ethan
is now rounding out the left hand it's
looking great ladies and gentlemen I
think keep me contender for first place
on the floor stamping why would an award
for this yeah
or am I like one of those nude models in
an art like art class yeah we do
[Music]
give you a good Belen admiring his war
to cover our beautiful 360 camera was in
the bathroom someone was trying to go
after an afternoon and problems that
oddly enough like I thought that took
many more hours and it actually did but
we're well on our way we've got
technical problems out the way and we're
gonna get our second scene done third
technically
[Music]
but they have arm like you just removed
your arm murder seemed too big to do
this great desk ready this isn't right
it looks like a man and studying's lines
and see your badge
[Music]
your credentials okay Catherine I need
to see your credentials my lines are up
in here I rode the damn thing you've got
four scenes done of 60 and we have two
dicks
wait we have four done
[Music]
to tell that
[Laughter]
[Music]
No yeah yeah like I think that always
weirded me out because I was like how
are they updating the actual hardware
with hi how you doing
thank I'm sorry you can look at me
actually but first of all ladies and
gentlemen do you know who I am
then go away take a drink and calm down
there are so many spiders at these huge
like just face eating spiders okay so
we're on the street as this place is
haunted by farts as is gazebo there used
to be a bathroom in this bathroom
they say the dump happened stinky
Marvel and his glory also - just like in
cases PC spiders
spiders
okay you put shoes on I'll put my
flip-flop these on there all the way
upstairs also we do okay we're going
like the path
no no other snake so Luke yeah at
nighttime they said there were snakes
and they're made in he was like there's
a black snake and a pink snake and
they're mating so be careful the sinks
all the way down
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't like it right hello
it's be Ethan going on a ghost adventure
on the housey house don't like that
[Music]
always my proper weight I'm waiting
wait that's not kind of doing you see
that no see it's flickering no it's
gonna start blinking
okay we're spooky spooky you saw
yesterday all right yeah well it's not
on camera so I've never found that room
spooky though really
[Music]
well let me tell you a thing or two
about a singer - it better filming once
twice three times four times for the bad
for five to six days wait two hours 14
hours 12 years you know it's really not
a means nothing I can't see your blue
hair not only do you sound like Dana
Carvey but you kind of look like him too
then there's serious really good
planning and scheduling and then not so
serious following and did this skillful
bottle tossing and then this serious
whoa what is even are you just listening
to it is he is he assaulting you Anna
see this is the time to get BTS because
it happens with the boom mic stage with
Abu Ben Mike oh goodness
Secretary's made our cheeks they just
saw any secretions look at those one
[Music]
what got a little change I'll change
yeah sure okay so we're gonna go
friends okay so this is a front door
yeah they don't finish can you give a
[ __ ] my ways so before my tour was so
rudely interrupted here's the ground
outside this guy's nice and doesn't
scratch
it's got but with a night but and there
we go this way and this is the area that
we call the party area this party area
we call it the party area because this
crazy cool party like oh oh no murder
scene party buddy-buddy party that
didn't make any sense we knew what's in
here oh my gosh it's a garage and it has
a Hummer in it this okay that's new I
did not notice that that was there and
then back here there's there's a
restroom that has somebody shirts that
have been there for a couple days now
and then there's a Fiat ah dude is there
a light to turn
yeah here's the theater this is where we
watch the game of thrones the other
night there is a bug found my glasses
you see that you see the bug that just
yeah playing on my glasses while I was
giving this tour Hey
uninvited he found new huh anyway so
yeah then there's a stage thing you can
perform huh see here is he
you see if I could stop this it's like
please enjoy
for you
[Music]
Ethan you're doing great job you trying
to give me a taste of my own medicine
because you eat it's really hard to be
sassy when you've got a food full mouth
full food full mouth full mouth full
food full moon mouthful wait what's your
what's your weapon of choice
sweet Ben's Wheat Thins for now beggars
can't be choosers yeah well I mean if
you had to choose what would be your
snack tater chips just regulars no I
need something I need those Hawaiian
sweet expression feels good that's good
[Music]
is so much softer than now I'm a bad
costume person for not bringing inside
[Music]
that's all we're going look at that
interior design take the BTS camera into
this room it doesn't do it but I don't
think that water damage is there when we
got here yes take a look easy they agree
what's your observation it looks so fun
absolute insanity
what would
Leslie beautiful crazy
Freddie done done my price you're gonna
miss something and it's gonna go so well
hidden that the next people miss it I'm
so many sticky notes in there like
encyclopedias you know read some goodies
for us Colonel colonel colonel colonel
[Music]
what makes Gatorade that color and
should we be putting in our bodies I
like this guy and so you heard the chief
[Music]
I could leave a sticky note you just
murder where should we put it
873 but now this doesn't say we didn't
murder all right I will not speak if you
get possessed I'm [ __ ] a little cherry
let's get out there
I didn't even know you were there mix
don't even have to pretend to be
possessed because I will [ __ ] beat
outtie but you have to do that so I can
use a flashlight if I need to get out
[Music]
[Laughter]